12 hectares de sites devenus trop petits
hachette livre souhaite s'agrandir ou
plutôt se moderniser et a besoin de 20
hectares une information transmise il y
a un an aux maires des communes
concernées maurepas et coignières on
pouvait pas sur la communauté d'agglo on
a effectivement ça fait un an que l'on
cherche désespérément années un terrain
d'une vingtaine d'hectares on l'a pas on
ne l'a pas on peut tout au plus leur
offrir ce qu'ils ont déjà donc c'est pas
possible tu selon eux
on a fait avec mon collègue grigori
yaris thiémé maire de maurepas on a fait
effectivement des propositions
d'aménagement de nos élus respectifs
pour qu'ils puissent en ligne et limite
s'étendre en hauteur 1 donc densifier
sur le site il semble que techniquement
ça soit pas possible
le départ serait envisagée à l'horizon
2026 vers allainville défavorable le
maire de coignières souhaite connaître
le futur du terrain dont hachette livre
et le propriétaire vous partez très bien
700 emplois partent et nous on souhaite
une réindustrialisation du site souhaite
un nouveau que ce site revivent et de
l'emploi attire de nouvelles entreprises
voire plusieurs entreprises il ya déjà
douze hectares
donc il ya des possibilités de comment
dire de réindustrialiser le site
alors on leur a demandé bien entendu
s'il avait un projet tandis qu'il n'est
pas de projet à l'heure actuelle pour le
site
les entreprises qui demandent à
s'implanter sur 50 ans on est quand même
un territoire innovant on a aujourd'hui
une visibilité le dire mondial dans les
colonnes de la gazette le groupe
hachette indique que le projet va faire
l'objet de plusieurs procédures de
consultation des instances
représentatives du personnel
conformément à la loi et dans le respect
du dialogue social le maire de maurepas
grégory gars restiez n'a pas souhaité
s'exprimer à notre micro
un communiqué de presse des deux villes
a été publié le 30 avril dernier